[Music]
okay thank you very much fit and thank
you all for coming here and and having
me here I'll talk to you about many
things first I wanted to introduce
what's the Barcelona supercomputing
Center for use if you if you're not from
around this is the Spanish Supercup
vidiian facility so we have the largest
computer in Spain usually so it goes out
real fast and we upgraded every once in
a while so last upgrade was 2017 it was
a second computer in Europe at that
point with 13 peda flops of compute
power it's actually a combined machine
with it has lots of CPUs but also we
have machine with GPUs for newer
trainings and so on and in about a year
and a half we're gonna have the biggest
computer in Spain again with almost 200
petaflop
of computer power so what does this mean
so what do we do there actually only
about a tenth of the people at the
centre work and supporting the users of
this machine there's about 500
researchers this is a slightly old group
for oh but there's a lot of people they
are working on many many sciences on
computer science of course but also on
life sciences and engineering astronomy
there's a energy less a lot of people
doing climate research and my group we
do a little bit of transversal work
there because we do data analytics and
visualization for many of the research
projects that go go on on the on the
center and also directly with some
companies and we do a little bit of a
very very wide range of things and I had
a hard time choosing one project to talk
to you about so I decided to really bore
you and run you through a lot of things
that we do and the idea is that I also
wanted to talk not just about the
projects but why we do so many things
and so different things I did work on
quantum computing and speed set but I'm
not going to talk about that actually so
this is just a flash of what's to come
so we do Bissell ization and we do
movies with those visualizations we do
Interactive's
we do a lot of data analytics to support
the visualization and interfaces and I
want to divide more or less the
presentation in in three tracks so I'm
going to talk about projects that are
related to data streaming first let's
let's go back to summer 2015 so sooner
is a music festival hearing in Spain
Electronic Music Festival is very famous
it's been going on for almost 25 years
and they have now a dedicated technology
fair so-called solar plus D and it's ins
in the spirit of Southern Southwest
where they mixed entertainment
industries with technology industries
and try to get both both words to talk
to to talk to to each other and so we
went there turns in this year
this is sonal village the center of the
mon week fair and we deployed a lot of
raspberry PI's through the through the
through all the different scenarios so
the village is over there we have about
three devices and we put them any of
these raspberry PI's to track people's
wi-fi's so something that you can see
everywhere more or less now cell phones
tracking you people tracking you in the
malls we were doing this in a little bit
of an artistic approach because we
wanted to let people know that they were
we in tracks and what they could what
people could do with this and so we had
on a book on our booth a real-time
screen like this where we were tracking
all of the different scenarios where
people were moving where they were from
15 minutes ago
we had this in real time and we we also
have the ability to track people
individually through their MAC address
actually this is illegal to do right now
because law has changed but we were able
to give people their own individual
trajectories so if this is our map of
the six different stages if you now
think of each of these circles as a
clock then you can imagine you can plot
somebody's trajectory like if they went
into the two o'clock in some room and
then
stated until four and then they went out
to another room so we had a look a
little signature for everybody to to see
what they did through the festival it
lasts three days and we were tracking
about 30,000 people per day in this
festival now what were we doing behind
this we were just collecting data so
this was the real time and after the
festival we did a lot of analytics and
we do a lot of business intelligence for
this honor festival organizers this is
just like a heat map of the expected
activity at each of the rooms by day by
time not just the actual number of
people but the expected number of people
depending on how many people were on the
festival the different artists
what relationship to what what they were
trying to get from some people so behind
this was something that is very
well-known it's like a lambda
architecture if you want to talk a
little bit more changes so we had
raspberry PI's collecting data and we
were using Cassandra at that time for
for some reasons and then data was
growing into two tracks on the left
you had the speed track where we're
doing real-time analytics and
visualization and we had people getting
these individual trajectories into
t-shirts so they were going to the booth
and and they could just get a picture
from with their activity and a little
bit of visualization and statistics and
on real time but then on the right we
were just storing in things like crazy
so that we could have some very good and
deep analytics after the festival what
we do is not go to music festivals we
work like I said with a lot of Science
and Industry
so this architecture that we use for
this project we actually use it for
something like this so this is the
process of treating water here in
Barcelona there's a huge plant by the
South and one of these parts is called
inverse osmosis is a part of the
industrial plant and it has well most of
the plants here in Spain and in Europe
are used SCADA systems where they can
just track thousands of sensors and
signals from all over all over the plant
what you see here is a very Matic
parallel treatment of water so you have
a row water coming in from the from the
left and then it's divided in parallel
into different tracks and energy is
being used to pump this water through
filters okay so this is just the
collection of filters and then you get
drinkable water by the right so what you
have in the middle is a lot of machines
a lot of things that are basically
generating data there's a lot of
controls operators are doing stuff to
these things and there's also where
there are regulations demanders the
stack external things that come in
influence this thing so what people want
from this is usually to spend very
little money on operating these plans so
maximizing euros per per hour of benefit
the problem is that you have to spend
money to pump the water so that takes
energy and when the water is dirty the
filters get to get dirty too and so that
takes a little bit more more energy so
it's more costly so you should replace
the filters but represent filters also
takes money okay so this is a project of
predictive maintenance but also
optimization of energy because the
problem is coupled so there's a benefit
there is a some equilibrium at some
point where we can do the replacement of
filters now what we do here is exactly
we'll same architecture of data that we
use for solar and other projects we just
put this here we just have some
analytics in real time for the people to
look at at the plant but then we create
machine learning models in order to
predict when we do these people do have
to do replacements so with this in place
it's being tested this year since
January we have okay I'm not gonna go
through all of the charts here but we
can more or less forecast the chart on
the left of top we can more or less
forecast the behavior of the plant for
almost 30 days 25 days with this we can
do some predictions and and they're more
or less 20% accurate but this is really
really good so very wait so we always
get numbers that are much worse than
that so when you see in casual people
getting some like 99% accuracy or
whatever so this is this is actually a
huge success in the real world
20% error
amazing with all these protocols in
place we have these people get about a
7% reduction in energy consumption which
for industrial plant is a lot of money
right so this is what we do this is
Rajasthan we have been doing this for a
few years and now we're moving into
something a little bit more streamlined
which is the small signal to cap
architectures so we take in SCARA
and we're doing connections into a kafka
injectors and then we do in a stream
processing of the data and just
deploying things directly into different
apps so we're just putting databases for
procedural analysis but we're trying to
do the analysis in real time now because
what we want to do is a little bit more
ambitious I'm gonna plug here a couple
of ongoing projects that we have and
they are models this one is a gap
halfway between finishing in this
project we have this architecture to try
to do an automated control of the
operation room of the water in the whole
of our cellar so there's a control room
we have tons of screens you have
probably seen one of these life or in
movies there's people with a lot of
experience there that they know what
they're doing and this is very difficult
to train and it's very difficult to
transfer this knowledge of people into
something else so what we're
investigating is the idea of
transferring and their optimal ways of
operating these very complex control
rooms into a neural network trained with
some reinforced learning techniques so
that we can have this knowledge stored
somewhere in some algorithm and the
company can basically have a little bit
more leeway in to who is operating when
and they can be prepared when there's an
emergency and the people that are
sitting right there don't have enough
experience to deal with those
emergencies we can also do of course
what we were doing before which is
basically I normally earlier anomaly
detection and and so on there are other
project that we're doing it's a little
bit way more non-sense it's we just
started about a month and a half ago is
with photo cooper sedona and it's very
related to what we did with solar so
food october Salona is you probably
heard of it so they have this large
Stadium in the let's courts neighborhood
and they also have all the all of the
area around where they have the store
the museum and this area around receives
about five million people per year so
it's a lot of people so it's normal
operation there's more people outside
the stadium than when there's a match
and there's about a hundred thousand
people inside the stadium and what we're
doing here is giving it a giving these
architectures a little twist because
they also have scatter so we can just
play our streams and do machine learning
optimizations but what we want to do
here is also take advantage of this our
supercomputer not just for training but
for operating these type of facilities
and what we do in this case is we
simulate the people around so we have
Asian based models if you haven't heard
of them it's like the professional
version of The Sims or the Sim City so
you have all of these little artificial
agents moving around interacting with
each other deciding what to do and
interacting with their environment and
we you use this because we want to
simulate where they want where are they
going to go or how to optimize their
flow and in particular because the
stadium is going to be in renovations
for the next two years and they're not
going to close it down so they're going
to renovate the stadium part by part and
they're going to close down a little bit
section of the stadium each week so
really one or two weeks different
patterns stadium is going to be closed
down and this changes a lot of the
evacuation plans for them so instead of
having to recalculate all of the other
Croatian plans every week which for our
architecture studios is very difficult
we are going to get not just the parts
that are closed and the plans for the
stadium but also the kind of people that
are there how many children and how many
tourists are there that don't know the
stadium and the area around so that we
can recalculate the evacuation plans on
this on the same day
using your supercomputer this leads into
some optimized
rerouting of signatures on signals on
the stadium and we can plug the
backing into the scatter systems and
their controls of the of the stadium and
we can redirect people that according to
what we want to do with them now let's
talk about data pipelines and
documentaries so I mentioned that we are
a visualization group and this is
actually how we started we started I had
a background in in advertising in TV
advertising between animations so when I
went to the supercomputing Center and I
saw all this data that they had this
beautiful 3d data I thought that we
could do something with it as well it
was much better than what scientists
were doing with their commercial
software now the problem here is that I
knew that we had to go into film tools
right because we wanted to create images
from the data that looked like this so
what we do now many years from now so we
grew out of this realization because we
will processing data
like you see I'm going to go back to
that and what we do and what we started
doing in our visualizations there are
four very very very heavy processing and
they take a lot of time for creation and
we want to create documentaries for
dissemination like this one this is
called brutal humans is one of the
latest one we did and there are actual
documentaries that we submit to film
festivals and so it's typical routes as
you do if you're a film creator but we
are scientist and we work with from
creators and we work with with with the
other scientists work on these topics in
there so what was the idea here we
started doing this because we wanted to
create first hyper-realistic
database on sessions the UC
supercomputer in this case this is a
documentary for research projects that
are trying to simulate human organs in
order to at some point
couple them and create a simulation of a
whole human being and this remote
simulations are very very realistic
because they use thousands of computers
to do their calculations and we wanted
to show and impress people to see how
much realistic correlations by making
them very very realistic
now doing this at some level takes a lot
of effort so we're still on this line of
Coen hyper-realistic or photorealistic
visualizations of these computer
simulations so it's not just humans
whether this also of course aerodynamics
is the biggest thing that you will see
of from supercomputer as energy either
small Q stirs by all stuff waters what
we wanted so the name we haven't settled
so on how we call us in super nice
visualizations what we wanted was photo
real renders of the data we wanted to
use it for presentations we wanted to
use it for documentaries we want to use
it for websites so this is a LED for
that is not for short exploration of
database is something that they do once
or twice in a big project and the idea
is to get maximum impact so you get a
communication that really really dives
through the realism of the simulations
that really makes it to a lot of people
and increases no more no more abilities
in this way so how do we need to do this
well we know that we cannot use the
tools that the scientists used to do
visualization so they use everyday tools
which are perfectly good for exploring
and analyzing and understanding their
data but they don't have really very
good photorealistic output what we need
is to couple to the film intercept tools
what they used to do at commercial
advertising is to do films and film
inertia tools are amazing they have so
much power so they living working on
creating images for decades now and so
they do I gotta give you a lot of
freedom and the people that know how to
use these tools are also very amazing
they really know how to use them there
they go really really fast and the
images on the right are were Dom from
people world up by people that work
actually in the group so they will come
from clean companies and they've worked
on transformers on Game of Thrones so we
work with these people so we go hire
animators from these companies when they
get really burnt out of their fascist
schedules you know if you haven't seen
you know what
working like in the film industry you
don't want to you don't want to lose too
much time on that when they really know
how to work on this level of detail that
really know how to work with vast
amounts of data and textures and times
and supercomputers so they really have
some idea on on how we can push data
visualization to this edge we want it to
be super beautiful but it's very
important that it's accurate because the
moment the we lose realism and we lose
accuracy the scientists you should just
click off
they say this is art or a largest
depiction of my work so this is not true
and they have really really keen eyes so
when they see these fluid simulations on
in the movies they immediately can tell
ya but this is [ __ ] so this waves
never do that on the sea or whatever so
an explosion would never have that type
of shape and it's something so fast that
you don't see it but they have trained
eyes so they can really tell and they
shut off and then they dismiss it
immediately so we want to keep on the
data visualization side but also make it
really beautiful so that people from the
general audience can understand and
enjoy the simulations and for that we
really need to work with them so we need
to be real tight because even though you
know I I do work as a liaison because I
have this scientist background and we
have other peoples and group that come
from sighs background but we don't know
all of the things that they work on so
we have to work with them side by side
and make sure that why they use these
color schemes and would this be better
than did we do something wrong here so
we have to do this very carefully and in
order to not lose accuracy also on the
spatial and time sense we have to use
their data directly in the film industry
software so we cannot do this usually
these software comes with simulators for
fluids or simulators for physics these
type of engines they come inside but
they are really really rough and they
don't show the actual science that you
use you you you would get from our
realistic simulations so we have to just
convert the data into something that the
film industry tools understand and this
is a lot of the work and this is how we
started the group so typical production
pipeline in a film
is all of that except for the two boxes
circled there in red and these are the
two boxes that make us different so we
do a lot of data processing that these
people don't do and conversion so what I
call theta casting is usually we we
don't usually have actors in some of the
documentaries we have people talking but
usually we just use the data to do the
communication so we really need to see
how good the data is so we sit together
a lot who inspect using the software how
it would look like so we create a little
bit of a discarding who's a bad actor
who's a who's a good actor in in this
data sense and then we have to convert
because data comes usually in numeric
formats or categorical formats but it's
never never in a format that something
like a commercial software will use and
so we created we started creating a lot
of software for data conversions we can
read from many scientific formats and
this is the type of stuff that we
convert into so Maya blender twisted max
Houdini and then different render
engines like Arnold render render man
redshift render cycles and we're pushing
the edge a little bit here because we
work with autodesk with work we work
with Arnold render we work with render
month to get there inert so of the
software that they use so that we can
create and their own formats and we can
write plug-ins for them so we
collaborate with these people we get a
lot of return from them they also give
us these licenses for using their
software in our supercomputers and
rendering very fast so we when we use
this you also need hundreds of computers
to do the render and we also can create
directly
software the data in the format that
they need and this is sometimes is open
information sometimes they give us this
format and sometimes we do some reverse
engineering of the data formats that
they use and we do this for surfaces for
textures for voxels and so on the good
thing about 3d designs over commercials
over it that's very stable it's easy to
find people that know how to use it it's
a little bit expensive in the case of
Maya it's cheap in if you use blender
which is open-source it's a little bit
less stable because it changes too much
and this it's not easy to find people
that work professionally that use
blender and then we use many many
different types of renders I'm not going
to go into the differences then but they
are all driving every day to become more
and more realistic which works very well
for us which is exactly what we wanna do
now by the end I'm gonna show you if
there's a little time a little clip from
what we did this is not per se a
documentary so another type of project
that we create booties are like short
technical videos that scientists can
show in conferences and presentations or
on their web sites this is this was
called created for the company
electronics they create a lot of devices
like pacemakers in this case it was a
stent for aneurysms and they were they
we created a little video for them and
with this video for this video we use
data from simulations and how the stent
works inside and also videos from people
doing the operations and getting the
getting the stent in place in a
simulated environment so we could get a
realistic idea I want to talk about the
previous last part last third track of
what I wanted to say so what is it about
data visualization in a more traditional
sense so what do we do there we started
doing videos we realized we could do
these data pipelines very very big
because we had scientist dumping us like
one terabyte of data and we had to
create a video out of that and then we
we had scientists actually asking us how
do we start information from these data
so we we started hiring data scientists
to do these transformations of the data
and then we realized we were also a data
science group maybe we could do the
machine learning for our own projects
and at some point we also had people
asking us ok now you have created all of
this but I don't want a video I want to
interact with the data I want to
fluor I want to communicate with an
interactive which is different than a
video and so we have this other type of
project where we do this interaction and
more typical visualization so for
companies and for in our scientific
project we create interfaces such as
this this is a process four hours ago
Sedona again communicating some machine
learning that models that we did on how
to prioritize the renovation of the
piping in Barcelona and the underlying
model has like 400 variables which
translates into about 20 layers of
information so this is a very dense and
technical interface it's not it's not
usable for the general audience it's
somebody it's for somebody who is a
little trained the same thing for energy
traders so we did an interface here for
European project called as - as free and
we have the prediction of whether that's
going to be more or less wind than the
than the average or expected wind for
some season and it's a sub seasonal
schedules a new product from the
European Commission weather services
this is for a company predicting the
flow of ash from volcanoes and the
impact on airplanes on trajectories and
how they can reroute and this is
something we do for fun so we also do
taking the interaction to communicate
things around this is something we took
also - sonal is an interface showing the
relationship between music styles with
data gathered from Wikipedia and how
people interact with these interfaces
it's very fun because you see them they
are playing around with discussion it
was a touchscreen so we'll do a little
bit of experimentation our research line
formally is that we try to improve the
usability of data visualization so we
test with our trackers you have probably
heard of them they are used a lot for
for advertising needs so try to
understand how people use different
websites so we use them to try to see
which help associations work and how and
what we can do to make it make them more
better so we research a little bit on
interaction and this is the type of
thing that we bring also do these
festivals on
try to do experiments and that we were
going to play with people with Victoria
data and bitter reality data on touch
screens data on different formats sound
so we do experiments there to to
discover new things we also do a little
bit of communication like this is a
project for the Puente movement if you
haven't heard about it similar to the
mid-to movement from from but in Spain
at slightly different but related and
there was about a two and a half million
tweets with the analytics for this and
also we did an interactive visualization
which is online we push try to push a
little bit the technology on how to
bring many many data points and
interpretation into mobile phones and
stuff like that so a little bit of what
makes us different here in the data
visualization track of the group is that
we use our computational muscle to
process as much data and machines as we
as we can we really push that and when
we get this project that have some data
that we can extract information or
process it and it takes a lot of effort
and the also the different part is that
we do be solely session with a lot of
testing so we care a lot or the user and
usability making it useful and usable
and so we do a lot of testing in our
development and deployment you have seen
this in companies but for Academy it is
like totally come from coming from the
future another plug for a project that
we're working on right now and we
started yesterday
it's a project called Media Portal and
it addresses one important ADA we think
it's a very important name so what you
see on the left is the Copernicus data
store the climate data store it's the
European services the free service where
you can download data like climate
historic data present data and all the
future scenarios and it takes calling
takes a lot of coding so what we're
doing is we're creating a graphical
interface for the for journalists try to
not not to do coding so they can just
create visualizations on the fly and
we're recruiting journalists so that we
can do the user testing
make it very good for them if you know
any just let me know so finally I want
to make a quick tour about the group so
right now we're sixteen people 18 people
and there's a one missing here we have
one more animator just showed up and
then we have a couple new hires on the
top right for instance you have a lot of
guys coming from Chile to do mobility
human mobility and you will see the
backgrounds are very different so we
have people from animated animate
industry we have UX experts we have data
scientists of course we have data in
data engineers how do we do this how do
we work together I try to think that
it's very important for that we really
keep together and we really keep working
together this will probably limit us in
the number of people that we would have
that we can have but I think it's part
it's important for the type of projects
that we do that we can coordinate and
talk to each other although we don't
have a separate teams doing the science
and engineering and UX and visualization
because the type of projects that we do
really try to address things problems
that are have these things really knit
together and they work so these four
corners we have design science
interaction and technology this is more
as well and were the people in the group
is now so we have more or less
everything covered and this is the type
of project that we tried this is why we
have this idea this is by design so it
doesn't happen by accident
it has good and bad parts okay so the
good things that we have really really a
large number of heterogeneous skills and
the bad part is that everybody's I used
to work in different things so it takes
a lot of effort to convince programmers
to use Trello and all the designers to
use JIRA or sana so it's very
complicated to get everybody on board on
the tools and and and the timings and
the workflows the good thing also is
like I mentioned we can do really really
different project a wide range and
strange project but it's that's really
bad too so we do really really different
projects all the time so it drives us
crazy it takes a lot of time to adjust
and
many times we have problems that will
project on sync with each other so
really we cannot we will never get to do
one process or the other we have to be
get used to working in parallel with two
three sometimes five six projects and
this is very difficult to manage and
work so it takes a little bit of effort
there and that's what it thank you very
much and I will check all the questions
you want
I don't do quantum computing anymore
but if you want to talk about that
that's fine there's a quantum computing
group at BSC
one of the people in my group I also
work there with them and but I have
retired from me from the area yeah
thanks for the talk so my question is
you have different experiences from
different large-scale projects what is
the number one challenge for each data
science project you would mention number
one challenge for data projects data
science projects human is that there's
two and one is obvious and it's written
the future is very difficult and this is
what everybody wants and then the other
one we have is deploying on on actual
people's infrastructures this so we push
a lot we get sometimes very good
predictions or at least at the
industrial base line so we get very good
predictions and they would improve the
products but then there's a lot of IT
problems and infrastructure problems and
budgetary and timing problems getting
our software installed in somebody
else's facility is usually very
complicated and since we don't work with
the same type of client every time and
it's a type of project we have to learn
from scratch every time so this is for
right now our biggest problem anywhere
else
yeah all right somebody there's one more
one more
Jelena yeah so what's your approach to
data visualization in different projects
do do the visualizations from scratch or
do you have something which you can you
reuse across those projects that's a
good question we have a lot of tools for
prototyping that we reuse some are
commercial like tableau that's the one I
like a lot but the the team uses a lot
of Python and and in programming tools
and then we are slowly building our set
of tools that we reuse for each project
but when there's a visualization a
specialization that needs to be unique
and whatever we usually build it from
scratch so we we have every time more
tools that we can reuse but the approach
is to tailor the visualizations as much
as possible to the needs and
requirements of the problem so that
makes it all so difficult to reuse so we
don't reuse a lot of the really
front-end part but all the back end
usually is getting better d3 to use d3
yes a lot that's our main tool
[Music]